PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
CASSANDRA CHOSE HER HAIR
OVER THE COMPETITION.
SO, YOU'RE NOT READY
TO CUT YOUR HAIR?
NO.
YOU JUST GOTTA LEAVE MY SET,
OKAY?
I'M GONNA GO BACK TO TEXAS,
GET SOME HAIR EXTENSIONS,
AND HOPEFULLY YOU WILL SEE ME
AS A FUTURE MISS USA.
AND WHEN SARAH BECAME
DISTRACTED BY A CRUSH ON KIM,
HER PERFORMANCE SUFFERED.
KEEP YOUR TRAIN BEHIND YOU.
YOU'RE NOT STAYING CENTERED.
STAY CENTERED.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
THANKS, SARAH.
NINE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
I JUST WISH IT HADN'T
COME DOWN TO SARAH AND I.
YEAH.
WILL SARAH AND KIM PLEASE
STEP FORWARD?
OF COURSE, I WAS HAPPY
WHEN TYRA CALLED MY NAME.
I WANTED TO BE CALLED.
I WANTED TO BE THE ONE
WHO WOULD CONTINUE ON
IN THE COMPETITION.
KIM.
BUT SOMETIMES I THINK
THAT SARAH DESERVED IT MORE.
GO AHEAD.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S TAKE A PICTURE.
LET'S TAKE ONE PICTURE
OF EVERYONE.
WE HAVE A CAMERA
IN THE HOUSE NOW
AND ALL OF THE GIRLS
ARE GOING CRAZY.
HEY, GIRLS, SMILE.
OH, THAT'S CUTE.
[OVERLAPPING CHATTER
AND SQUEALING]
THESE GUYS ARE CRAZY.
[OVERLAPPING CHATTER]
OH, DAMN,
THIS IS GETTING SERIOUS.
I LIKE TO HAVE A GOOD TIME
AND WE WERE BEING CRAZY,
YOU KNOW.
THIS IS OUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
DIANE DIDN'T WANT TO BE
IN THE PICTURES.
I THINK THAT WAS WHY
SHE WAS THE RING LEADER.
I WANT SEXY.
SEEING THE OTHER GIRLS
BEING SKINNY AND SLIM AND THIN,
I'M DIFFERENT--
MY LOOK IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
I HAVE CURVES
BUT YET I'M COMPETING
WITH THE SKINNY MODELS.
ONE, TWO.
KIM, YOU LOOK LIKE A PIMP.
YOU WANT TO SEE
MY SECRET BAG?
COME HERE.
I WANTED TO GET
BIGGER BOTTLES.
CAN I TAKE A SWIG OF THIS
BEFORE I LEAVE?
NO.
I ACTUALLY DON'T WANT TO
SHARE IT WITH ANYONE.
I'M SURE YOU DON'T.
GIRL, I'M GONNA
TELL YOU SOMETHING.
TO DO YOUR BEST...
YOU NEED TO POSE IN FRONT
OF THE MIRROR
AND DO FACES THAT AREN'T THE
FACES THAT YOU NORMALLY DO.
I HELP THESE GIRLS
'CAUSE I WANT THE COMPETITION
TO BE ITS BEST.
BRING CORYN OUT HERE.
LISA-MOM WANTS TO TALK
TO YOU.
GET OUT HERE!
LISA-MOM.
COME ON, CORYN.
I WANT TO
TELL YOU SOMETHING.
WHAT?
CORYN, DO YOU
WANT TO PUT YOURSELF
IN A LABEL OF BEING
A SPORTS GIRL,
LIKE, WORKING FOR ADIDAS?
I'M TRYING TO DO
ALL-ROUND STUFF.
EXACTLY.
WHEN LISA DRINKS,
SHE JUST LETS HERSELF
COMES OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE.
YOU NEED TO
STOP WORKING OUT.
NO, I DON'T, 'CAUSE
I'M NOT WORKING OUT.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU
SEEN ME WORK OUT HERE?
YEAH, BUT GIRL,
I'M JUST SAYING.
CORYN-- ALL SHE TALKS ABOUT
IS WORKING OUT--
HOW HER LEGS JIGGLE,
BUT SHE'S, LIKE, SO SKINNY.
SHE'S HARD LOOKING.
DID THEY NOT TELL YOU
THAT YOU LOOK TOO MUSCULAR
AND THAT YOU--
NO, THEY DIDN'T SAY
I LOOK TOO MUSCULAR.
YOU'VE GOT
A VERY MUSCULAR BODY.
IT'S DEFINITELY-- IT'S VERY
SORT OF SPORTS KIND OF MODELING,
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO BE ABLE
TO WEAR DRESSES.
FOR YOUR ADVANTAGE,
IT'D BE BEST
IF YOU JUST ATE
AND YOU DIDN'T WORK OUT.
WHY WOULD I LISTEN TO
SOMEBODY I'M COMPETING AGAINST?
THAT'S KIND OF STUPID,
ISN'T IT?
THEN DON'T.
I'M NOT GOING TO.
LISA SAY I'M TOO THIN
AND I NEED TO STOP WORKING OUT.
BUT WHATEVER,
I DON'T LISTEN TO HER.
I DON'T CARE.
I WAS WORKING OUT
LAST NIGHT, SO...
TYRA MAIL.
QUICK, QUICK!
WHAT DOES IT SAY?
QUICK.
"PLUSES AND MINUSES,
WHO SAYS MODELS CAN'T DO MATH?"
I'M, LIKE, THE WORST
PERSON AT MATH.
I'M DAMN GOOD AT MATH.
YOU GUYS READY TO HANG OUT?
SO, YOU ALL KNOW
WHERE YOU GUYS ARE?
YOU GUYS ARE AT SMASHBOX,
AND THIS IS HOME
OF L.A. FASHION WEEK.
WE WANTED TO TALK
TO YOU GUYS
ABOUT TURNING
YOUR NEGATIVES INTO POSITIVES.
YOU KNOW,
YOU GUYS ARE SO LUCKY
TO HAVE TWIGGY
SITTING ON THE PANEL.
WHEN TWIGGY WAS MODELING,
YOU KNOW,
THE WOMEN
WERE MORE VOLUPTUOUS.
THEY HAD A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT LOOK.
SO, FOR HER TO COME IN
AS A SMALL GIRL
WHO'S VERY, VERY THIN
AND CHANGE THE PERCEPTION
OF THE MODELING INDUSTRY,
THAT WAS HUGE.
YEAH, I KNOW WHO
TWIGGY WAS.
SHE WAS, LIKE,
THE SUPERMODEL
WHO CHANGED THE WHOLE
SKINNY INDUSTRY.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
NOBODY'S PERFECT.
EVERYONE'S GOT THEIR FLAW,
AND YOU GOTTA LEARN
HOW TO HIDE IT
OR MAKE IT WORK FOR YOU.
WE'VE BROUGHT TWIGGY
FROM BEHIND THE DESK.
TWIGGY, COME ON OUT HERE.
OH, IT'S SO NICE TO SEE YOU
CLOSE UP.
TWIGGY IS, LIKE,
A ROLE MODEL FOR ME,
AND SHE'S REALLY HELPFUL,
AND IT REALLY SEEMS THAT TWIGGY
WANTS US ALL TO DO WELL.
SO, WHY DON'T YOU
TALK TO THEM ABOUT--
MY NEGATIVES.
I HAD SO MANY NEGATIVES.
I WAS TOO THIN,
I WAS TOO SMALL.
MY EARS ARE TOO BIG,
AND ACTUALLY,
IF I HAD GONE
TO A MODEL AGENCY IN 1966,
WHICH IS
WHEN IT HAPPENED TO ME,
THEY WOULD HAVE ALL
TURNED ME DOWN.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED WAS,
THE HAIRDRESSER LEONARD,
WHO WAS ABOUT AS FAMOUS
AS VIDAL SASSOON,
SAT ME DOWN AND HE SAID,
"I WANT TO CHOP
ALL OF YOUR HAIR OFF."
I WENT, "OH, MY GOD,
YOU CAN'T CHOP MY HAIR."
"AND I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
VERY BLONDE."
THEN THEY CUT IT
AND THEY COLORED IT
AND THEY CUT IT AND
THEY COLORED IT,
SENT ME OFF
TO HAVE MY PHOTOGRAPH TAKEN.
THE GUY WHO PHOTOGRAPHED ME
IS A GENIUS.
HE'S A MAN CALLED
BARRY LATTIGAN,
WHO STILL WORKS IN LONDON,
AND THAT WAS IT.
I WAS GETTING BOOKINGS
TO PARIS AND, YOU KNOW--
TO DO
THE FRENCH COLLECTIONS.
I WAS SO DIFFERENT,
I WAS SO NEW,
AND THAT LOOK
HADN'T HAPPENED YET.
I DIDN'T KNOW, BUT
I WAS THE NEW LOOK.
SO, I MEAN, I THINK THE THING
I'M TRYING TO SAY TO YOU IS,
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMETHING,
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO USE
WHAT YOU'VE GOT AND BE TRUE
TO YOURSELF, I THINK.
GO AHEAD.
MY QUESTION IS, I THINK THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO RUNWAY,
I HAVE, LIKE,
THIS CONFIDENCE ABOUT ME,
BUT IN MY PICTURES,
IT NEVER SHOWS.
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA?
SOMETIMES, BUT MY GOAL
IN LIFE IS TO BE A LEGEND.
THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I WANT TO DO,
SO THAT AT LEAST,
BY THE TIME I'M 25,
I HAVE A COMFORTABLE
HOUSEHOLD NAME.
IF YOU'RE JUST THINKING,
I WANT TO BE FAMOUS,
I WANT TO BE A LEGEND,
I THINK YOU'RE JUST
WASTING YOUR ENERGY.
YOU SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING AT
THE MOMENT YOU'RE DOING IT.
ONE OF MY ISSUES, BEING
A VOLUPTUOUS MODEL,
UM, OR CURVACEOUS,
IS SHOWING THAT IN MY PICTURES.
I HAVE TO, LIKE, GO ABOVE,
STICK OUT MY CHEST,
STICK OUT MY BUTT,
AND, I MEAN, I DON'T WANT TO
LOOK TOO LIKE A PORN STAR
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
OH, I DON'T THINK YOU DO
AT ALL.
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD EVEN
THINK OF THAT AT THE MOMENT.
YOU KNOW,
THE CAMERA SEES DEEP.
IT REALLY SEES
RIGHT INTO YOUR SOUL.
I MEAN, IT'S ONE THING TO
WALK DOWN THE STREET
AND SEE SOMEBODY,
YOU KNOW,
CURVACEOUS AND VOLUPTUOUS
LIKE MYSELF,
BUT ANOTHER THING
TO PUT THAT TO USE.
SO, ARE YOU GUYS COOL?
IT WAS A GOOD CHAT?
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE
THIS WOMAN A HAND.
SHE'S BEEN
THROUGH EVERYTHING.
BYE!
SMASHBOX IS CO-OWNED
BY DEAN AND DAVIS FACTOR,
SO I'M GONNA BRING
DEAN AND DAVIS OUT HERE.
GUYS, ARE YOU BACK THERE?
THERE YOU GO.
THIS IS DAVIS, AND THIS
IS DEAN RIGHT HERE.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A LITTLE QUESTIONNAIRE
WE'RE GONNA PASS OUT.
I WANT EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
TO WRITE WHAT YOU THINK
YOUR NEGATIVE IS
THAT CAN BE TURNED
IN A POSITIVE,
AND WHAT YOU THINK
THE OTHER GIRLS' NEGATIVE IS.
I THINK A LOT OF GIRLS,
WHEN IT WAS TIME
TO FILL OUT THE PAPER,
WERE A LITTLE NERVOUS.
AND GIRLS, I DON'T WANT YOU
TO PUT YOUR NAME ON IT.
THIS IS LIKE AN ANONYMOUS
BALLOT, JUST SO YOU KNOW THAT.
I THINK THAT LISA
MIGHT BE PRETTY HARSH,
'CAUSE SHE SEEMS TO BE
PRETTY JUDGMENTAL
ABOUT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I THINK THE PERSON
THAT IS GONNA TAKE THE CRITICISM
THE HARDEST IS CORYN,
AND THAT'S MAINLY BECAUSE
SHE KNOWS
LISA HAS BEEN
DOGGING ON HER BODY TYPE.
I'M HONEST. I'M HONEST
THROUGH THIS WHOLE THING, MAN.
- WE ALL KNOW.
- WE KNOW, LISA.
ARE YOU DONE?
SO, LET'S
START OFF WITH JAYLA.
JAYLA, COME ON,
STAND UP FOR US.
MOST OF YOU ALL KIND OF
SAID THE SAME THING.
YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT YOUR EARS.
LET'S SAY A HAIRDRESSER
PULLS YOUR HAIR REAL TIGHT.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO EVEN
TWIST YOUR HEAD A LITTLE,
'CAUSE IF YOU TURN
YOUR HEAD A BIT,
YOU CAN MAKE THAT
KIND OF DISAPPEAR.
BRE, SOMEONE SAID FRONT
TEETH COME OUT A LITTLE FAR,
AND A LITTLE BIT OF THE TYRA
BANKS' FOREHEAD GOING ON.
IF THE CAMERA IS HERE,
IF YOU TIP YOUR HEAD UP,
IT GETS A LITTLE HOITY,
IT GETS A LITTLE SUPERMODEL.
IT ALSO HELPS YOU
ELONGATE THAT NECK.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE GONNA GO
TO NICOLE NOW.
LET'S SEE,
WHAT DO YOU HAVE THERE?
YOU'RE TOO PALE.
WHAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO DO,
IF YOUR PALE SKIN
IS GONNA BE THE THING
THAT YOU'RE ROCKING,
YOU MIGHT WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU PROTECT IT.
YOU PROBABLY BURN EASIER.
MAKE SURE YOU'RE WEARING
SPF ALL THE TIME.
- I'M VERY CAREFUL.
- GOOD.
NOW, DIANE,
IT'S REALLY INTERESTING,
AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
WROTE THIS,
BUT THEY SAID,
IN PERSON,
YOU'RE BUBBLY,
YOU'VE GOT THIS LIGHT.
BEAUTIFUL SKIN,
THE SMILE,
AND THEN YOU GET
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
AND IT BECOMES
THIS SULLEN THING.
YOU'RE VOLUPTUOUS
AND SEXY,
SO I THINK IN THE CLOTHES
THAT YOU WEAR,
YOU KNOW,
JUST PLAY THAT UP
AND PLAY IT UP MAYBE
IN YOUR ATTITUDE A LITTLE BIT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT NIK.
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
PROBABLY MORE
OF A KIND OF
LIKE A BUBBLE EYE,
YOU'VE ALWAYS GOT TO BE AWARE
OF WHERE THAT LIGHT IS.
IF IT IS TOO HIGH,
YOU CAN CATCH, LIKE,
A REALLY
DARK SHADOW UNDERNEATH,
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LISA.
WHAT ONE OF YOU WERE
GETTING, UM, IS THAT
SOMETIMES AT A DISTANCE YOU CAN
READ A LITTLE CROSS-EYED.
THAT'S SO FUNNY.
MAYBE JUST TURN YOUR HEAD
A LITTLE BIT, RIGHT?
KIMBERLY.
UNTONED ASS
AND LOVE HANDLES.
DAMN, WHO WROTE THAT?
OH, YOU WROTE THAT?
- OBVIOUSLY.
- I LOVE HOW SHE ADMITS THAT.
PROBABLY BECAUSE YOUR HIPS
ARE NARROWER,
IT'S THE ILLUSION THAT
YOUR WAIST IS WIDER.
I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOUR ASS,
'CAUSE I REALLY HAVEN'T
GRABBED IT.
COME OVER HERE--
LET ME GRAB YOUR ASS.
LET ME SEE.
COME OVER HERE.
FLEX IT.
OH, OKAY, IT'S NOT-- YOU DON'T
HAVE AN UNTONED ASS.
YOU CAN GO BACK.
KYLE, YOUR NECK
CAN LOOK A LITTLE SHORT,
SO YOU'VE GOT TO
WORK REALLY HARD
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR NECK
LOOKS LONG ALL THE TIME.
- LAST BUT NOT LEAST IS--
- CORYN.
CORYN-- YOU WANT TO
READ THAT ONE OUT?
- UH--
- JUST READ IT.
TOO SKINNY FOR ME
AND MUSCULAR.
I SAY CORYN IS SKINNY
AND MUSCULAR AT THE SAME TIME.
I DON'T MEAN THAT
AS A BAD THING,
BUT NOT EVERYBODY
IS GONNA LIKE THAT.
SHE HAS A GREAT BODY
TO SHOOT.
LET'S SEE
A SOFT PRETTY LOOK.
THAT'S WHAT I DON'T GET,
THOUGH.
HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO BE
SOFT? I MEAN--
BUT YOU'RE SUCH
A PRETTY GIRL.
YOU'VE GOT,
LIKE, THIS GREAT INSIDE
THAT JUST BUBBLES FORWARD,
SO IT'S ABOUT MAKING YOURSELF
A LITTLE MORE APPROACHABLE.
DO YOU GUYS FEEL LIKE YOU
LEARNED SOMETHING HERE TODAY?
THIS WILL REALLY HELP US
ON OUR NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
SAY THANKS TO THESE GUYS.
THEY ROCK.
CORYN'S MAD THAT LISA
KEEPS POINTING OUT HER FLAWS
BECAUSE SHE'S DONE IT
MORE THAN ONCE.
I WANT TO SEE LISA GO.
I'M TIRED OF HER PUTTING
PEOPLE DOWN.
IT'S JUST GONNA
MAKE YOU FEEL BAD.
ACTUALLY, IT'S
MAKING ME FEEL BETTER
SO YOU WON'T BE TALKING TO ME
OR ANYTHING AT ALL, YOU KNOW?
WE JUST
CUT OFF THAT WHOLE THING.
THAT'S FINE.
LISA, I DON'T CARE
WHETHER SHE THINKS I HAVE
A GOOD BODY OR NOT.
I JUST WANT THE JUDGES
TO DECIDE THAT.
I'M NOT HERE
FOR HER TO JUDGE ME.
I JUST DO NOT LIKE YOU.
NOW THAT I'M TELLING YOU
THAT I DON'T LIKE YOU AND STUFF,
I FEEL A LOT BETTER.
CORYN WENT TO LISA AND
WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T LIKE YOU.
I DON'T WANT
ANYTHING TO DO WITH YOU.
SO YOU WON'T BE TALKING TO ME OR
ANYTHING AT ALL, YOU KNOW?
WE JUST CUT OFF
THAT WHOLE THING.
THAT'S FINE.
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO
DO WITH THAT?
I'M LIKE, OKAY.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SIT
NEXT TO ME?
NO, I DON'T.
WHY ARE YOU
STILL TALKING TO ME?
I DON'T HATE YOU.
IT'S TOO MUCH ENERGY.
I JUST TOLD HER
THAT I DON'T LIKE HER.
WHAT'S UP WITH HER?
SHE JUST IRRITATES THE HELL
OUT OF YOU.
NOT THAT I DISAGREE
WITH YOU,
BUT WHAT IS IT THAT,
LIKE, YOU DISLIKE?
SHE CONSTANTLY
RIPS PEOPLE DOWN
BUT MAKES HERSELF,
YOU KNOW,
OUT TO BE THIS GOOD PERSON
OR WHATEVER.
I AM KIND OF HAPPY
THAT CORYN FINALLY SPOKE OUT
AND TOLD LISA HOW SHE FEELS.
I JUST FIND A LOT OF
WHAT SHE SAYS HYPOCRITICAL,
YOU KNOW?
OR, LIKE,
SHE'S GIVING ADVICE ONE WAY,
AND THEN I SEE HER DOING
THE SAME THING.
THAT BOTHERS ME.
EVERYONE LET HER
BE MAD AT ME,
AND THEY KIND OF ALMOST JUST,
LIKE, WENT ALONG WITH IT.
I JUST THINK IT'S MESSED UP,
BUT WHATEVER.
GUYS, IT'S TYRA MAIL.
TYRA MAIL!
YES.
"ACCENTUATE THE NEGATIVE.
BE READY AT 11:00."
"XOXO, TYRA."
ALL RIGHT, COOL.
WELCOME, LADIES.
- HI.
- I SEE MISS J.
I LOVE MISS J., SO I WAS
EXCITED AS SOON I SEE HER.
I UNDERSTOOD YESTERDAY THAT YOU
LEARNED ABOUT YOUR FLAWS.
TODAY, WE'RE GONNA
PUT THAT TO THE TEST.
TODAY'S PHOTOGRAPHER
FOR THE CHALLENGE
IS NO OTHER
THAN MR. JAY GOLDMAN.
JAY, COME ON OUT.
JAYS GOTTA STICK TOGETHER.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
SOMETHING A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
WE'RE GONNA
REVERSE THE ROLES.
TODAY,
YOU'RE GONNA DIRECT ME.
YOU CAN TELL ME WHERE YOU
WANT ME TO SHOOT FROM,
FROM WHAT ANGLE,
AND I'M GONNA DO THE BEST
TO MAKE
YOU ACCENTUATE YOUR FLAW
AND HIDE YOUR FLAW.
MISS BRE, YOU'RE UP.
- HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
- HOW ARE YOU?
SO I AM ACCENTUATING MY FLAWS
RIGHT NOW, RIGHT?
- STRAIGHT ON.
- STRAIGHT ON-- HERE WE GO.
ALL RIGHT,
NOW I'M HIDING THEM.
- YES.
- HOLD ON. OKAY.
I'M VERY UNSURE OF
MYSELF RIGHT NOW,
AND IT'S KIND OF
FRUSTRATING ME.
JUST A SECOND.
YOUR SECOND IS UP.
NICE WORKING WITH YOU,
SWEETHEART.
WOULD YOU LIKE IT FULL LENGTH?
WOULD YOU LIKE--?
I THINK FULL LENGTH,
SO I'D HAVE TO BE A LITTLE BIT--
- OKAY.
- JUST--
EXACT, MY DEAR.
RIGHT THERE.
DIANE COULD HAVE JUST BEEN
A LITTLE MORE SEXY
AND MORE OUT THERE--
MORE PADOW!
WE ARE ACCENTUATING
THE EARS, CORRECT?
YES.
- THANK YOU.
- ALL DONE?
YOUR FLAWS WERE WHAT?
MY EYES ARE TOO BIG.
YOUR EYES ARE BIG.
- YEAH, BUG-LIKE.
- OKAY.
GIRLS, DON'T BLAME
THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
BLAME YOUR PARENTS
FOR BAD DNA.
HARD AS NAILS.
I LOOK TOO MEAN ALL THE TIME
AND THEN MY BODY IS TONED.
HARD TO HIDE MY BODY.
ARE YOU READY?
NOW MY FLAW
SUPPOSEDLY IS A LAZY EYE.
WE'RE GOING TO HIDE
YOUR FLAW NOW.
- THANK YOU, LISA.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
MY FLAW IS THAT
I'M REALLY PALE.
OKAY.
LIKE, AS WHITE
AS YOU CAN GET ME.
LORD KNOW YOU WHITE.
GOOD.
HERE WE GO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
- MY FLAW IS MY SHORT NECK.
- OKAY.
SO FOR THE ONE WHERE I'M TRYING
TO, LIKE, SHOW IT OFF,
I WANT, LIKE, FULL LENGTH
SO I CAN LOOK LONG.
OKAY.
AND THEN FOR THE ONE
THAT I'M TRYING TO--
- WHAT'S THE OTHER ONE?
- HIDE IT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DEFINITELY WANT TO HAVE
A FULL LENGTH.
SURE.
FIRST ONE.
I DON'T THINK I'M DOING
AS WELL AS I'D LIKE TO BE DOING
IN THIS COMPETITION, SO I REALLY
NEED TO STEP IT UP.
THANK YOU.
READY.
I LOOKED-- HONESTLY,
I LOOKED SO MUCH
LIKE WHERE'S WALDO,
IT'S SCARY.
WE'RE BACK. WELCOME,
WELCOME, WELCOME, WELCOME.
OKAY, JAY, SO ARE WE
READY TO DO THIS?
I'M READY.
WHAT'S THE PRIZE?
WELL, THE WINNER
GETS TO GO TO A SPA.
SHE GETS TO CHOOSE
TWO FRIENDS AS WELL.
SO, WHO DO YOU THINK?
FROM THE DIRECTION THAT WAS
GIVEN TO ME AND THE POSING,
THE WINNER IS KYLE TODAY.
YAY!
OH, IT FEELS AWESOME.
LIKE, I PROMISED MYSELF
THAT I HAVE TO WIN ONE CHALLENGE
AT LEAST.
WHICH TWO OF THESE MODEL TRAMPS
ARE YOU GONNA TAKE WITH YOU?
I THINK I'M GONNA GO
FOR KIM AND THEN CORYN.
OKAY.
[APPLAUSE]
GOOD LUCK AND
CONGRATULATIONS AND--
- THANK YOU.
- NICE JOB.
GOOD FOR KYLE.
SHE DESERVES TO WIN. SHE DOES.
MAYBE I'M JUST BITTER
'CAUSE I HAVE A LAZY EYE.
HI, WELCOME TO THE BEAUTY
AND LIFESTYLE.
THANK YOU.
GETTING MY FIRST MASSAGE,
IT WAS REALLY RELAXING.
IT WAS SO NICE.
IT FEELS REALLY GOOD.
ARE YOU NICE AND SMOOTH?
YEAH, MY SKIN IS
REALLY SMOOTH.
I WANT TO FEEL.
SHE'S SMOOTH.
IT WAS NICE JUST TO TALK
BETWEEN US,
'CAUSE WE ARE
MORE CLOSE TO EACH OTHER
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS.
I LIKE BRE.
LIKE, YOU GUYS AND HER
ARE, LIKE,
MY THREE FAVORITES.
YEAH, MINE ONLY, TOO. I DON'T
LIKE REALLY ANYBODY ELSE.
- YEAH.
- LISA, HELL NO.
WELL, LISA JUST, LIKE,
DECIDES
TO, LIKE, RANDOMLY
TAKE CHARGE WITH THINGS,
AND I'M LIKE,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
LIKE, YOU HAVE NO IDEA
HOW TO TAKE CHARGE.
I'M TOO TONED
AND I'M TOO THIN,
BUT YET
YOU CAN SEE HER RIBS,
AND YOU
YOU CAN'T EVEN SEE MINE.
REALLY, SHE'S JUST
REALLY JEALOUS.
SHE LOOKS SO OLD,
DOESN'T SHE?
IT GUESS IT MIGHT BE
FROM THE ALCOHOL
OR IT MIGHT BE
FROM THE SUN EXPOSURE.
I JUST DON'T LIKE HER.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S TYRA MAIL.
"IN THE MODELING BIZ,
"SOMETIMES YOU'VE GOT TO
FAKE IT 'TIL YOU MAKE IT.
BE READY AT 6:30 A.M.,
TYRA."
FLY LIKE YOU-- NO.
FAKE IT LIKE YOU HAVE IT,
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SOMETHING.
WE ARRIVED AT THE STUDIO.
MORNING, JAY.
THE FIRST THING WE SAW
WHEN WE GOT IN THERE
WAS A SURGICAL ROOM.
IT WAS A BED.
THERE WAS TOOLS.
I REALLY DIDN'T WANT TO DO
THE PHOTO SHOOT ANYMORE,
BECAUSE NOW I WAS SCARED,
AND I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY WE NEEDED TOOLS
AND CHEMICALS
FOR OUR NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
HELLO, MR. J.
MORNING.
SO, WHO CALLED ME MR. J?
- ME.
- YOU DID?
WELL, ACTUALLY,
WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW IS,
MY NAME IS DOCTOR JAY,
AND WE'RE OUT HERE IN FRONT
OF THIS OPERATING ROOM
TO TAKE YOUR NEGATIVES
AND REALLY FIX THEM.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA KIND OF
POKE FUN AT PEOPLE
WHO TAKE THAT PLASTIC
SURGERY TO THE EXTREME.
WE WANT THIS TO LOOK
LIKE HIGH FASHION,
AND IT'S GONNA BE
VERY, VERY EDGY.
SO NOW, I WAS TRYING TO THINK,
WHO COULD DO THIS?
SOMEBODY WHO IS A SUPERMODEL
TURNED MASTER PHOTOGRAPHER.
COME ON OUT HERE,
MISS THING.
IS IT A GUY?
[APPLAUSE]
THAT'S ALL I GET?
JANICE DICKINSON,
EVERYBODY.
BOW, BOW.
GET ON YOUR KNEES, GIRLS.
WHAT DO WE HAVE HERE?
AND I WAS JUST LIKE,
OH, MY GOD.
I KNOW JANICE
IS GONNA SLAUGHTER ME.
COME ON OUT HERE,
MISS THING.
[APPLAUSE]
THAT'S ALL I GET?
JANICE DICKINSON,
EVERYBODY.
- HEY.
- MWAH!
JANICE JUST
POPPED OUT OF NOWHERE,
AND SHE'S
THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
I WAS REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE HER.
I THOUGHT, LIKE, AWESOME.
LIKE, THAT'S THE KIND OF MODEL
THAT RESEMBLES ME, I THINK.
I'M NOT THE BITCH ANYMORE.
I'M THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
I THINK IT'S BENEFICIAL TO HAVE
ME, JANICE DICKINSON,
WORLD'S FIRST SUPERMODEL
TURNED PHOTOGRAPHER.
I HAVE BEEN MODELING
FOR 30 YEARS,
AND I'LL STILL BE
MODELING FOR ANOTHER 30 YEARS.
I'M LIKE THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT JUST DOESN'T GO AWAY.
SO TODAY, WE'RE GONNA HAVE FUN
WITH THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE DECADENCE
OF PLASTIC SURGERY
AND TAKING IT TO EXTREMES.
DON'T WORRY, GIRLS--
THE PROCEDURES WE'RE DOING TODAY
ARE FAKE AND EXAGGERATED.
THEY'RE JUST FOR FUN.
JANICE KNOWS ALL ABOUT
THIS STUFF.
LISA, WE ARE GONNA
TAPE YOU UP EVERYWHERE
AND GIVE YOU
THE EXTREME FACELIFT.
LIKE YOU GET CAUGHT
IN A WIND TUNNEL LOOK.
BRE, WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
LOOK LIKE
YOU'VE GOT THIS RIDICULOUS
CHEEK IMPLANT SURGERY.
CHEEK IMPLANTS!
JAYLA, TURN AROUND.
LET'S SEE THAT BUTT-- YEP.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
A BUTT IMPLANT.
WHAT?
KYLE, WE ARE GONNA GIVE YOU
A LIP IMPLANT.
LIKE JAY.
NIK, NOT EVERYTHING'S GONNA BE
A SURGICAL PROCEDURE.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A LONG HAIR
EXTENSION TO THE FLOOR.
- NICE.
- INSANE. ALL RIGHT?
- NICOLE.
- YEAH?
TODAY WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
LOOK LIKE YOU HAVE
THIS FAKE, FAKE,
FAKE TAN.
OKAY.
- KIM.
- HOOTERS!
- BOOB JOB.
HOOTERS!
BOOB JOB.
DIANE, GIRL,
WHAT DO YOU THINK
WE'RE GOING TO DO
WITH THAT?
I DON'T KNOW.
WE'RE GONNA BIND YOU
ALL THE WAY UP.
WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU A BREAST REDUCTION.
CORYN, WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU LOOK
LIKE THE BOTOX CREATION.
LIKE ME.
ALL RIGHT?
SO, ARE YOU READY?
HIT IT.
I WANTED TO BECOME A MODEL
BECAUSE I SAW LAUREN HUTTON
ON THE FACE OF--
ON THE PAGES OF "VOGUE"
WHEN I WAS LIKE NINE YEARS OLD.
THAT'S WHY--
AM I TOO HEAVY?
NO.
JANICE IS A LITTLE BIT
INTIMIDATING AT FIRST,
'CAUSE
JANICE IS SO FORWARD
AND SHE JUST CONFRONTS YOU
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
ARE YOU A LESBIAN?
- YES.
- THAT'S HOT.
- OKAY.
- CAN I HAVE A KISS?
NICE.
JUST BE LIKE SOFT
AND BE YOURSELF.
I LOVE JANICE--
I LIKE HOW BLUNT SHE IS
AND THAT SHE DOESN'T TRY
TO BEAT AROUND THE BUSH
OR ANYTHING.
SHE JUST
TELLS YOU HOW SHE SEES IT.
- LISA.
- JANICE.
I WENT UP TO HER,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"SO, JANICE, WHAT'S UP?
"MY NAME IS LISA.
ARE WE GONNA TALK?"
I AM DETECTING A LITTLE BIT
OF ATTITUDE FROM YOU.
NO.
I DON'T HAVE ATTITUDE.
LET'S GO FIND A STUMP
TO FIT OUR RUMPS.
DO YOU KNOW WHY I COINED
THE TERM "SUPERMODEL"?
- WHY?
- 'CAUSE I CAN.
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE TO ASSIST
YOURSELF IN THIS ENDEAVOR?
WELL...
NOTHING.
SHE DRILLED ME
WITH EVERYTHING
THAT I COULD
POSSIBLY BE DRILLED ABOUT.
EVERYTHING.
I'M REALLY HEALTHY.
I'M THE HEALTHIEST ONE OUT OF
THIS WHOLE GROUP OF GIRLS.
DON'T DISS THE OTHER GIRLS.
I'M NOT DISSING ANYONE.
SHE DISSES EVERYBODY.
- YOU'VE GOT TO STOP--
- WHO DOES?
YOU DO.
YOU'VE GOT TO STOP DISSING--
LISTEN TO ME.
I'M SALLY JESSY RAPHAEL.
YOU'VE GOT TO STOP DISSING
EVERYBODY RIGHT NOW.
I'M NOT DISSING ANYBODY.
JANICE WAS TALKING TO LISA
AND I HEARD HER SAY,
"I DON'T TALK ABOUT
THE GIRLS," OR WHATEVER,
AND I JUST STOPPED, 'CAUSE
THAT'S NOT TRUE,
AND I'M LIKE,
"YES, YOU DO.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE GIRLS
ALL THE TIME."
SHE JUST
CAN'T KEEP HER MOUTH SHUT
AND STOP CRITICIZING
OTHER PEOPLE.
GIRLS, GIRLS-- IS THIS GIRL
DISSING EVERYBODY?
EVEN IF IT'S JANICE,
SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHO I AM.
SHE CAN'T POINT
THE FINGER AT ME.
SHE JUST MET ME.
AND THEN FOR CORYN JUST TO SAY,
LIKE, I'M THE BAD ONE
AND ALL I DO
IS INSULT EVERYBODY--
THAT IS NOT TRUE AT ALL.
I'M JUST TOTALLY OFFENDED
RIGHT NOW.
I WANT THEM TO BE ABLE
TO INTERACT WITH THE SET,
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
NOT GETTING IT.
I THINK YOU CAN
GET IT OUT OF THEM,
EVEN IF YOU HAVE TO
REACH DOWN IN THEIR THROAT.
I COULD DO THAT.
OKAY.
LOVE THE HAIR,
JUST HATE THE DRESS.
SO YOU JUST WANT HER IN PUMPS
AND HAIR?
YEAH, I WANT NUDE, JUST--
AND HERE'S WHAT YOU'LL DO--
KEEP THE PUMPS.
YEAH, YOU CAN CROSS YOUR LEGS
AND HAIR OVER THE BOOBS.
AND THE HAIR WILL BE COMPLETELY
OVER YOUR BOOBS.
I WANT HER NAKED.
YES. GOOD, GOOD, GOOD, GOOD,
GOOD, GOOD, GOOD, GOOD, GOOD.
OKAY, LONGER, LONGER.
HOLD THIS THING UP IN THE AIR
LIKE YOU'VE GOT THE PRIZE.
THAT'S HOT.
OH, WORKING WITH JANICE
WAS AMAZING.
IT WAS SO MUCH FUN,
'CAUSE I WAS NAKED,
AND I HOPE MY MOM'S
OKAY WITH IT.
WATCH THE PINS.
STUFF IT IN, HONEY.
I'M REALLY ANNOYED AT YOU.
YOU'RE GIVING ME THE SAME
EXPRESSION IN EVERY FACE.
I NEED MORE.
YOU BETTER GIVE IT TO ME.
OTHERWISE, I AM NOT TAKING
ONE MORE FRAME OF YOU, GIRL.
YOU HAVE NOT SEEN DIVA YET.
I WANT TO SEE SOME EXPRESSION
IN YOUR FACE!
I GOT MY SHOT.
KISS THE MIRROR.
SUCK IN YOUR TUMMY.
YES.
THAT'S GOOD! STAY!
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
LOOK AT ME LIKE THAT.
THAT IS--THAT'S YOUR PICTURE.
BEST SO FAR.
SORRY.
YOU GUYS BETTER
STEP UP YOUR GAME.
I THINK THAT I SHOULD
DO WELL TODAY.
IF I DON'T,
I WILL BE ELIMINATED.
THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I WANT TO BE,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
I WANT TO DO,
AND I'M TRYING SO HARD TO DO IT
RIGHT AND DO IT PERFECT
THAT I'M NOT REALLY
DOING IT AT ALL.
FORGET TYRA,
FORGET EMMON.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
- BRE.
- BE BRE.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE EVERYTHING
YOU KNOW FROM THEM
AND TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
LOOK AT ME-- LOWER YOUR CHIN,
SIT UP STRAIGHT.
I DON'T THINK BRE HAS
CONNECTED
WITH THE CAMERA LENS
AT ALL.
- WHAT'S HER NAME?
- CORYN.
CORYN, I NEED SOFTNESS
OUT OF YOUR FACE.
SOFT, BABY.
BABY, BABY, PLEASE BE SOFT.
THINK TOILET PAPER.
THINK TWO-PLY.
EVERYBODY'S LIKE,
OH, MY GOSH.
SHE CAN'T SMILE.
WHOOP TI DO.
BUT IT'S HARDER
FOR SOME PEOPLE.
AND I WANT
SOFT, SOFT, SOFT.
I WANT SOFT!
- WHAT'S WRONG?
- NOTHING.
WHAT, ARE YOU BUMMED BECAUSE
JANICE WAS HARASSING YOU?
JANICE IS A LITTLE
UP AND DOWN.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
NO, I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND,
'CAUSE THAT'S HOW I AM.
YOU'LL STILL GO OUT THERE
AND YOU'RE STILL
GONNA GIVE ME LISA?
YES.
I AM SO EXCITED
THAT THEY'RE
GIVING LISA A FACELIFT
BECAUSE SHE LOOKS TOO OLD.
WELL, YOU KNOW,
SHE'S GONNA NEED ONE
IN, LIKE, SIX MONTHS.
WHATEVER-- SHE'S A YEAR AND HALF
OLDER THAN ME.
WHEN I'M A YEAR AND A HALF
OLDER THAN THIS,
I'M NOT GONNA
LOOK THAT OLD.
WE'RE GONNA LIGHT HER
THROUGH THIS GLASS,
AND WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THIS DIMENSION
SO SHE'S WORKING
AND SHE'S BEAUTIFUL.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS BRING IT FROM WITHIN.
WORK IT, GIRL.
DON'T LOSE THE LIGHT,
HONEY.
NO, NOT, AGGH,
NOT LIKE YOU'RE DRUNK.
IT'S SO NATURAL FOR HER
TO BE LIKE THAT.
DRUNK.
ALCOHOLIC.
ANY REMARKS
FROM THE SIDELINES
IS NOTHING BUT JEALOUS.
THIS GIRL'S A STAR.
NICE, NICE.
I WANT A FRESH-- THAT'S GOOD.
SMILE.
I WAS DETERMINED
I WASN'T GONNA
LET THAT MOMENT
CONTINUE ON.
I WAS GONNA CHANGE IT,
AND ONLY WAY I COULD CHANGE IT
IS IF I
ROCKED THE HOUSE.
I ROCKED THE HOUSE
FIZZLE DIZZLE TODAY.
YUCK, THAT STUFF
LOOKS DISGUSTING.
GIVE IT TO ME, GIVE IT TO ME,
GIVE IT TO ME, UHH!
HOLD THE LOOK.
TURN IT DOWN.
IT'S STILL GREAT.
IT'S AWESOME.
SO AMAZING.
THANKS.
YOU ARE REALLY,
REALLY GOOD.
OH, THANK YOU.
I WAS HAPPY TO SHOOT YOU.
WE'RE BASICALLY
JUST GONNA PAD YOU
UNTIL YOU FEEL UNCOMFORTABLY
BOOTYLICIOUS.
YEAH, OKAY.
NO, MORE WITH--
FAN YOUR RIGHT ELBOW
MORE TOWARD ME.
GIVE ME MORE, PLEASE.
MY BACK HURT SO BAD
AFTER THE PHOTO SHOOT,
BECAUSE MY BUTT WAS UP
IN THE AIR THE ENTIRE TIME.
VERY GOOD.
SEE, THAT'S GREAT,
BECAUSE
THEN WE BIND HER DOWN
AND WE MAKE HER FLAT-CHESTED.
AND THEN THIS COVERS IT.
MY COSMETIC SURGERY IS GONNA BE
A BREAST REDUCTION.
THIS IS MY CHANCE TO SHOW
THE JUDGES
THAT I AM VERSATILE,
AND I'M ABLE TO
EXPRESS MY BODY.
- OW!
- IT REALLY HURTS?
YEAH, 'CAUSE THEY'RE
TAPED DOWN LIKE--
- WITH GAFFER TAPE?
- NO, WITH OFFICE TAPE.
OH, YOU CAN'T BREATHE.
YEAH, IT IS ON MY CHEST.
IT'S LIKE, EHH!
IT'S A TOUGH ONE.
WELL, KEEP YOUR COMPOSURE.
WORK IT OUT OUT THERE.
OH, I KNOW.
JAY.
I NEED YOUR ATTENTION.
DON'T CRY
ON YOUR PRETTY MAKEUP.
YOU'RE PRETTY.
IT HURT VERY BAD.
I COULDN'T EVEN BREATHE,
SO I STARTED CRYING,
AND I'M JUST LIKE,
OH, MY GOD, YOU KNOW,
CAN ANYTHING GET ANY WORSE?
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT,
ALL RIGHT?
OKAY, I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY.
YOU ARE A RICH CONTESSA
FROM BARCELONA.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
NO, HOLD IT UP,
HOLD IT OUT.
WHEN I FIRST MET DIANE, I GOT
A HUGE SENSE OF INSECURITY.
DIANE NEEDS TO STOP REELING
HER HEAD
BACKWARDS LIKE,
LET'S SAY, A HORSE
WHEN IT'S READY TO WHINNY
AND LIKE, EH-EH-EH-EH.
SHE DOES THAT A LOT.
IT WAS PAINFUL.
I COULDN'T EVEN BREATHE,
BUT I PULLED IT THROUGH.
WHEN YOU GET HOME TONIGHT,
DON'T BE DOGGING ANYBODY
IN BACK OF YOUR BACKS,
BECAUSE THE REASON WHY
I REALLY DID
RISE TO THE TOP
OF MY FIELD IS,
I WAS REALLY A SISTER
TO MY NEXT MODEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR LETTING ME SHOOT YOU.
THE NEXT EXERCISE,
YOU PUT ONE LEG UP LIKE THIS
AND YOU BRING YOUR CHEST UP,
AND THEN YOU SWITCH.
WE'RE WAITING AT THE HOUSE
FOR TYRA MAIL
BECAUSE IT'S ONLY OBVIOUS
THAT PANEL IS COMING UP,
SO WE'RE TRYING TO
ENJOY EVERYTHING NOW
'CAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE HELL IS GONNA HAPPEN.
GO FOR IT, CORYN.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY EIGHT WILL
CONTINUE ON
"THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
WHERE'S LISA?
YOU KNOW, THE TRUTH IS,
GOING INTO ELIMINATIONS,
YOU DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHO'S AT RISK.
EVEN THOUGH MAYBE I FEEL LIKE
I'M DOING A GOOD JOB,
I HAVE NO IDEA.
I REALLY JUST DON'T.
I'M VERY NERVOUS
GOING INTO PANEL,
'CAUSE I'M NOT SURE IF MY
PICTURES TURNED OUT GOOD.
I'M NOT SURE IF I GOT
A GOOD SHOT OFF AT ALL.
I'M VERY CONCERNED.
I REALLY AM.
JANICE TOLD ME I WAS
BEAUTIFUL,
BUT SHE TOLD EVERYBODY
THEY WERE BEAUTIFUL, SO...
BUT I'M NOT GONNA SAY
MY PICTURES CAME OUT NICE,
'CAUSE WHENEVER I THINK
I DID A GOOD JOB,
MY PICTURES
BE LOOKING CRAZY.
YOU NEVER KNOW IF YOUR PICTURE
IS REALLY GOOD OR NOT
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE ARE GONNA THINK.
WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT DAY
IS GONNA BE YOUR LAST,
IT STARTS TO REALLY,
REALLY EAT AT YOU.
MAN, I'M READY
FOR THIS WEEK TO BE OVER.
I'M SICK OF TALKING
ABOUT MY FLAW.
LIKE, EIGHT TIMES
I'VE BEEN ASKED TODAY.
THE CHALLENGE THING
YESTERDAY, LIKE--
AT LEAST YOU DON'T HAVE BIG
TEETH AND A BIG FOREHEAD.
NO, NO, I'M JUST BIG.
SHUT UP.
WELCOME, LADIES.
- HI.
YOU GUYS ARE LOOKING MORE
AND MORE
LIKE REAL MODELS
EVERY WEEK.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR FOURTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING WHO WILL
BECOME AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU KNOW ABOUT OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING
CONTRACT
WITH TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWN PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMONE,
A COVER OF
"ELLE GIRL" MAGAZINE,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND OF COURSE,
OUR PANEL OF JUDGES.
MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
- MISS J. ALEXANDER...
- HI, BABYCAKES.
OUR FABULOUS
RUNWAY DIVA COACH.
TWIGGY, A LEGENDARY ICON
IN THE WORLD OF FASHION,
AND DEAN AND DAVIS FACTOR,
CO-FOUNDERS OF SMASHBOX
ENTERPRISES.
AND I'VE ACTUALLY TAKEN
SOME GORGEOUS PICTURES
WITH YOU, MR. DAVIS.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
- SOME GORGEOUS ONES.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
THIS WEEK, YOU'VE BEEN
TAUGHT HOW TO HIDE
AND FLAUNT YOUR MOST
UNFLATTERING FEATURE.
SO TODAY, THE JUDGES ARE GONNA
SIMULATE A GO-SEE
AND WE'RE GONNA PEPPER YOU
WITH QUESTIONS.
KYLE, YOU'RE FIRST.
SO KYLE, WHY SHOULD I HIRE YOU
WITH A SHORT NECK?
BECAUSE I HAVE A LONG BODY.
I CAN MAKE MY NECK
LOOK REALLY LONG.
JAYLA, SEE,
WE REPRESENT A CLIENT OF OURS
THAT ACTUALLY
SELLS EARRINGS.
I'VE GOT A BIG CANVAS
RIGHT HERE FOR YOU.
EVEN THOUGHT I HAVE A HARD
LOOK, I CAN ALSO MAKE IT SOFT.
I LEARNED SOME WAYS
TO HIDE MY BODY.
I THINK THAT MY SKIN
IS A POSITIVE FOR ME.
I DON'T KNOW--
CLIENTS WANT DIFFERENT THINGS.
LIKE, I'M JUST SOMETHING, LIKE,
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT I DON'T SEE
WRONG WITH MYSELF,
SUCH AS MY TEETH.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT MAKES ME
STAND OUT
MORE THAN ANY OTHER
PERSON WITH STRAIGHT TEETH.
YOU SHOULD HIRE ME BECAUSE
BIG BUG-EYES ARE BEAUTIFUL.
SO, DIANE,
PLEASE EXPLAIN TO ME
WHY I SHOULD HIRE YOU
TO SELL MY PRODUCTS.
I AM A BILINGUAL
SUPERMODEL.
WHY DON'T YOU GIVE ME A SENTENCE
IN ENGLISH AND IN SPANISH?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
MEANING,
I AM THE PERFECT SUPERMODEL
OR THE PERFECT PERSON
FOR YOU TO HIRE.
YOU NEED TO WORK
ON THAT ENGLISH A BIT.
WHEN I HEARD
THAT LAZY EYE WHOLE THING,
I DIDN'T EVEN THINK THAT
WAS ACTUALLY GONNA BE
ONE OF MY FLAWS.
I THOUGHT, THERE'S LIKE
SO MANY OTHER THINGS,
LIKE MY WAISTLINE, MY BOY CHEST,
MY UNEVEN LIPS, MY GAP.
I NEED YOU TO
GIVE ME THREE POSES
OF HOW YOU WOULD HIDE
YOUR FEATURE FLAWS.
MY FLAW IS THAT
I HAVE REALLY NARROW HIPS,
SO ONE IS SORT OF TURNING AWAY
FROM THE CAMERA.
NUMBER TWO COULD BE, YOU KNOW,
TO THE SIDE LIKE THIS.
ONE MORE COULD BE EVEN LIKE
CROSSING MY LEGS, YOU KNOW?
- THANKS.
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW IT'S TIME
TO EVALUATE YOU.
DIANE, YOU'RE FIRST.
DIANE, I FOUND WHEN WE
BEGAN TO ASK YOU QUESTIONS
THAT YOU ARE QUITE NERVOUS.
I ALWAYS FEEL WITH YOU
THAT YOU FEEL SLIGHTLY
EMBARRASSED AND YOU SHOULDN'T.
I MEAN, HOW COULD-- I MEAN,
I'M TRYING TO--
I MEAN, I'M BEING MYSELF.
YOU'RE NOT BEING YOURSELF.
YOU'RE SO NERVOUS.
WHAT WE WANT
IS A PLUS-SIZE PERSONALITY.
OKAY.
AND I KNOW
IT'S INTIMIDATING
IN FRONT OF ALL
THESE PEOPLE.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE
BEING A PLUS-SIZE GIRL
IS EVEN HARDER
THAN BEING A BLACK GIRL.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE BUBBLIER
AND YOU'VE GOT TO BE
MORE LOVEABLE.
YOUR PICTURE'S
GOT TO BE BETTER
TO GET THE SAME THING
THAT THE SKINNY GIRLS
BEHIND YOU ARE GETTING.
YOU'RE DISAPPEARING.
ALL RIGHTY, SO WE HAD
A SIMULATING PLASTIC
SURGERY PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
SHE HAD A BREAST REDUCTION
AND SHE'S BURNING HER BRAS.
OH, BY THE WAY,
YOU GUYS,
JANICE DICKINSON
SHOT THESE SHOTS.
I ALWAYS THINK MODELS
MAKE THE BEST PHOTOGRAPHERS.
'CAUSE NIGEL
USED TO BE A MODEL.
[LAUGHTER]
DIANE, YOU LOOK SO CLASSY
IN THIS PICTURE.
THAT'S WHAT
COMES OUT TO ME.
SO BASICALLY,
TAKE ALL THAT,
AND WHEN YOU COME
TO JUDGING,
LET'S SEE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONFIDENCE.
UP NEXT IS KIM.
WHEN YOU
ARE ASKED TO POSE, KIM,
YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT
YOUR POSE.
YOU SOUND LIKE CHARLIE
BROWN'S SCHOOLTEACHER.
WAH-WAH-WAH-WAH.
ALL RIGHT, KIM, SO YOU
HAD TO DO A PHOTO SHOOT.
YOURS WAS WHAT PEOPLE THINK
I HAVE BUT I DON'T.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOUR HANDS LOOK LIKE
CATCHER'S MITTS.
IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE PARALYZED.
IT'S HARDER TO TAKE A GOOD
PICTURE THAN I THOUGHT.
MODELING IS REALLY HARD WORK.
IT'S LONG, LONG HOURS.
♪ WAH WAH WAH ♪
ARE YOU STARTING ON ME
AGAIN?
I MAY LOOK LIKE A QUIET LITTLE
ENGLISH GIRL, BUT I'M NOT.
LISA.
WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT A CRITICISM.
YOU'RE LIKE,
OH, FORGET THE LAZY EYE.
THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER LITTLE THINGS.
SO YOU THOUGHT YOU'D POINT
THEM OUT TO THE PEOPLE
TRYING TO GIVE YOU A JOB.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
SHE HAD A FACELIFT.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU,
THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL SHOT OF YOU.
I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH YOUR FRAMES
BECAUSE YOU HAD SUBTLE
CHANGES AND MOVEMENTS
WITH YOUR FACE--
LIKE, YOU WENT
FROM THIS INTENSE FACE
TO, LIKE, A SMILE.
UP NEXT IS CORYN.
YOU CAME ACROSS
AS VERY SAD.
AS SOON AS YOU SMILE,
IT CHANGES YOUR WHOLE BEING.
GO TO A MIRROR
AND PRACTICE YOUR SMILES.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
CORYN WAS
ANTI-WRINKLING ACTIONS.
I CAN'T MOVE MY FACE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY,
BUT I CAN'T.
YOU'RE DEFINITELY PHOTOGENIC,
CORYN.
YOU CERTAINLY ARE.
ALL RIGHTY, SO, KYLE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
WHAT WAS
YOUR PLASTIC SURGERY?
I HAD, LIKE,
LIP INJECTIONS.
I LOVE IT.
YOU'RE CONNECTING, KYLE.
YOUR EYES ARE,
LIKE, FIERCE.
NEXT IS JAYLA.
YOU DEALT WITH US
BRILLIANTLY.
YOU WERE SO NATURAL.
YOUR PHOTO SHOOT WAS THE NEW
CRAZE IN PLASTIC SURGERY,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
BOOTY.
OH, BOOTYLICIOUS.
- A BOTTOM?
- YES.
AND LOOK WHO HER PICTURE
IS OF ON THE WALL.
I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU GUYS CAN SEE.
THAT'S A PICTURE OF J-LO.
BUT THAT'S A REAL ONE.
YEAH, HERS IS A REAL ONE.
JAYLA, YOU CAN GO FROM BEING
QUITE SAFE LOOKING
TO ACTUALLY BEING SORT OF
PUNK ROCK 'N' ROLL,
WHICH IS GREAT.
NICOLE.
NICOLE GOT
A REALLY FAKE TAN.
THAT SUNBURN LOOKS
LIKE IT HURTS.
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
STILL RESTING ON PRETTY
AND NOT PUSHING THROUGH.
YOU REALLY
NEED TO DO THAT.
- OKAY.
- ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS NIK.
NIK DIDN'T GET A SURGERY.
SHE GOT EXTREME HAIR
EXTENSIONS.
YEAH, YOU'RE TOTALLY
IN CONTROL-- IT'S WONDERFUL.
I'VE NEVER SEE A GIRL SO HAIRY
LOOK SO GORGEOUS.
WELL, THANK YOU.
BRE.
YOU LOOK A LITTLE DOWN
THIS WEEK.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE SMILE
AND THE LITTLE--
THE BRE THAT I'VE SEEN
BEFORE.
COMING IN HERE, Y'ALL CAN
BRING A PERSON DOWN SOMETIMES.
BRE, IT SEEMS LIKE
YOUR SPIRIT IS BROKEN.
THE CRITICISM.
YOU GOTTA KNOW WHO YOU ARE
WHEN YOU COME IN HERE.
IMAGINE WATCHING TELEVISION
WITH YOUR FRIENDS,
AND YOU'RE FAMOUS, AND YOU'RE
WALKING DOWN THE RED CARPET,
AND JOAN RIVERS SAYS, "BRE, SHE
LOOKS LIKE A PIECE OF CRAP."
AND YOU PICK UP THE PAPER
THE NEXT DAY,
AND YOU'RE ON THE COVER--
"WORST DRESSED OF THE YEAR."
WHEN YOU ENTER THE REAL WORLD
OF FAME AND SUPERMODELS,
THERE'S MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
CUTTING YOU DOWN EVERY DAY.
THERE ARE CHAT ROOMS DEDICATED
TO THE "I HATE BRE" FAN CLUB.
I'M NOT USED TO, YOU KNOW,
HEARING CRITICISM LIKE THIS
ON A REGULAR BASIS.
THIS IS TOUGH AND THIS IS NOT
WHAT I EXPECTED IT TO BE,
SO I GOTTA SHAPE UP.
ALL RIGHT, BRE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE SHE HAS
CHEEK IMPLANTS.
THAT COULD BE OUT OF ANY
HIGH FASHION MAGAZINE.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL PHOTO.
YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
BRING THIS LOOK AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS
YOU'RE DOING
IN THESE PHOTOGRAPHS--
BRING THEM TO JUDGING.
I WANT TO SEE THE MODEL
IN FRONT OF ME.
THANKS, BRE.
ALL RIGHT.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
NIK.
I LOVE NIK.
SHE LOOKS LIKE LADY GODIVA.
BRE.
BRE HAS A BEAUTIFUL FACE,
THAT'S FOR SURE.
BUT BRE, IN PERSON,
LIKE A BALLOON
HAD JUST BEEN BURST.
JUST, WHOOOO.
SHE DOESN'T SEE IT
AS CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM.
I THINK
SHE SEES IT AS ATTACK.
CORYN.
I SORT OF SEE THE SADNESS
AND THE SORT OF--
THE DEPRESSION IN CORYN
BEFORE I SEE THE MODEL
IN CORYN.
THE WORLD IS STILL
ON HER BACK.
- DIANE.
- SHE SEEMS A BIT DOWN LATELY.
SHE'S DEFINITELY TRYING.
SHE'S IMPROVED, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT SHE'S NOT A MODEL.
SHE DOESN'T LIVE IT,
SHE DOESN'T BREATHE IT.
SHE'S PROBABLY
JUST NERVOUS.
KIM.
THIS IS NOT A PARTICULARLY
GREAT PICTURE OF KIM.
SHE IS THE SORT OF
ODD ONE OUT IN THE BUNCH.
I LOVE HER LOOK.
I LOVE HER FACE.
I JUST LIKE HER
KIND OF ATTITUDE, I THINK.
LISA.
THERE'S ALWAYS
THAT QUIRKY GIRL,
KIND OF "REPTILIOUS" LOOK.
THE FACT THAT SHE WAS PICKED
TO HAVE THE FACELIFT,
DOESN'T THAT
SAY SOMETHING?
NICOLE.
TO ME,
SHE LOOKS LIKE A MODEL.
SHE'D WORK IN EUROPE,
SHE'D WORK IN LONDON.
SHE JUST LOOKS A LITTLE
DAZED AND CONFUSED.
I'M WILLING TO
GIVE HER THE CHANCE.
- JAYLA.
- SHE'S FUNNY, SHE'S SWEET.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT HER
THAT'S SO CUTE
AND SHE TAKES A GOOD PICTURE
AND SHE POPS,
BUT IT IS NOT A BIG POP.
KYLE.
THIS IS ACTUALLY MY FAVORITE
PHOTO OF THIS BUNCH.
SHE LOOKS LIKE
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
WHO ARE Y'ALL LIVING
NEXT DOOR TO?
EVERYONE ALWAYS WANTS
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED THE BOYS
NEXT DOOR
AND HAD MOST OF THEM, SO...
NINE BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
EIGHT PHOTOS IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE EIGHT PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE EIGHT GIRLS
THAT WILL STILL
BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
FIRST NAME THAT I AM
GOING TO CALL-- KYLE.
CONGRATULATIONS, KYLE.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
JAYLA.
NIK.
CONGRATULATIONS, NIK.
THANK YOU.
LISA.
NICOLE.
HOW DOES
THIS PICTURE GO, KIM?
I'M NOT SURE-- LIKE THAT.
CORYN.
WHAT WAS THAT LOOK?
I'M HAPPY, OF COURSE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WILL DIANE AND BRE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I WILL ONLY CALL
ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
WITH YOU, BRE, THE JUDGES
ARE FEELING
LIKE THIS INDUSTRY
IS SO CUTTHROAT.
BRE, I HAVE BEEN CALLED
EVERY NAME IN THE BOOK
TO MY FACE
AND BEHIND MY BACK,
AND, DIANE, WE FEEL LIKE
THIS PERSON
THAT WE THOUGHT
WAS SO SECURE AND SO VIVACIOUS
HAS A LITTLE INSECURITY
IN HER THAT WE ALL HAVE
BUT DOESN'T DO AS GOOD
A JOB COVERING IT UP.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
THE GIRL THAT MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO HANDLE
THIS TOUGH INDUSTRY
OR THE GIRL
WITH THE PERSONALITY
THAT'S A BALL OF FIRE
THAT'S JUST KIND OF
GLIMMERING SOFTLY?
YOU NEED TO
TOUGHEN UP, BRE.
[CRYING]
YOU CAN DO THIS.
THANK YOU.
BYE, SWEETIE.
THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
IT JUST HURTS,
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
BECAUSE IT'S ALL OVER.
THIS IS BUSINESS,
AND THIS IS TEACHING YOU
HOW TO GET TO
THE NEXT LEVEL,
SO I GUESS I HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE TO LEARN.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE GIRLS'
FIRST COMMERCIAL SHOOT
LEADS TO BACKSTAGE
BACK-STABBING.
WE HAVE THE SAME LINE AND I
THINK JAYLA STOLE MY SECRET.
AND BRIDGES ARE BURNED.
IT'S OKAY,
'CAUSE KARMA'S A BITCH.
AND THE FEUD BETWEEN LISA
AND CORYN BOILS OVER.
SHUT UP.
YOU'RE PRESENTING YOURSELF
LIKE A MORON.
ALCOHOLIC BITCH.